let's now move away from the world of
the hunter-gatherer and into the
dinnerware market so let's say we're
going to talk about two products two
types of dinnerware
we'll have cups on this axis and we will
have plates on this axis and let's say
we have a producer Charlie and if you
were to focus all of his time on cups he
could produce so let me let me put these
ten ten twenty thirty so if you were to
focus all of his time on cups he could
produce 30 cups and if you were to focus
all of his time on plates he could
produce ten plates and we're going to
assume he has a linear production
possibilities frontier so this is what
his PPF is going to look like let me
draw it a little bit actually connect
the two dots so that's I want to make it
more looking like a line so that's about
as good as I can do so that right over
there is the PPF for for Charlie now
let's think about his opportunity cost
and because this is a linear PPF his
opportunity cost does not change the
slope of this line is not changing it's
not that Bo shaped curve that we saw for
the hunter-gatherer so it's going to be
a fixed opportunity cost for one product
relative to the other at any point along
this production possibilities frontier
so let's say we're sitting over here
this will just make things simple to
just think about the end points and he's
producing 30 cups what is his
opportunity cost of producing 10 plates
well to produce 10 plates he's going to
have to give up those 30 cups so his
opportunity cost of producing 10 plates
10 plates is equal to 30 cups 30 cups or
if you want the opportunity cost for one
plate you just divide both sides by 10
and so you get the opportunity cost of
one plate is equal to three cups is
equal to three cups that's fair enough
now let's think about let's think about
the same scenario or let's think about
another producer in this market for
dinner where let's call her Patty if
Patty focused all of her time on cups
she could produce ten cups in a day and
if she focused all of her time on plates
she could produce 30 plates in a day
so that is and she also has a linear
production possibilities frontier so
that right over there is the PPF PPF for
Patty for Patty and let's think about
her opportunity cost for producing a
plate so the opportunity cost if she's
sitting right over here and she was
focused all on cups and if she wanted to
produce 30 plates and I'm intentionally
using the end points to make the math
more obvious if she wanted to produce 30
plates then she would have to give up
ten cups so her opportunity cost to
produce 30 plates 30 plates is equal to
ten cups is equal to ten cups or if you
divide both sides by 30 the opportunity
cost of her producing one plate one
plate in terms of cups is ten divided by
30 is 1/3 1/3 of a cup now this is
interesting we can now compare their
relative opportunity costs the
opportunity cost for Charlie to produce
a plate is 3 cups the opportunity cost
for Patty to produce a plate is 1/3 of a
cup so for Patty and yet especially when
you measured in terms of cups it is
cheaper for her to produce a plate she
has a lower opportunity cost than
charlie does in producing plates and so
relative to charlie we say because her
opportunity cost is lower in producing
plates one third relative to three we
say that Patty has the comparative
advantage comparative advantage
advantage in plates in plates relative
to relative to Charlie and we're going
to and it's not just because she can
produce and and we'll we'll see
situations maybe in the next video where
we actually show this it doesn't even
have to be the case that she can even
produce more plates in a given day this
is not why she has a comparative
advantage this is called an absolute
advantage and we'll talk about that more
she has a comparative advantage because
her opportunity cost is lower her
opportunity cost for producing a plate
is lower than it is for charlie now
let's think about what the other way
around who has a comparative advantage
in cups well if we divide both sides of
this right over here by 3
see that if or let's swap both sides so
the opportunity costs for Charlie of
producing three cups is equal to one
plate one plate or if you divide both
sides by three opportunity cost of one
cup is one-third is one-third of a plate
if we go to the situation for Patty so
let's go the Patty let's swap these two
around the opportunity cost for ten cups
ten cups is 30 plates 30 plates if you
divide both sides by ten the opportunity
cost of one cup is equal to three plates
is equal to three plates and obviously
and we've talked about this before the
opportunity cost of one incremental unit
that's the same thing as the marginal
cost of a cup the marginal cost of a cup
but anyway who has the lower opportunity
cost for producing cups well let's see
charlie can produce a cup at or
Charlie's opportunity cost for producing
an extra cup as a third of a plate and
Paddy's is three plates so Charlie has
the lower opportunity cost for producing
a cup so it's only one third plate
relative to three plates so this is
where Charlie has the comparative
comparative IDI comparative advantage
and what we're going to see is if both
of these parties specialize in their
comparative advantage and then trade
they can get outcomes that are beyond
each of their individual production
possibility frontiers so what we can see
is so for example they can get an
outcome where they are each able to get
15 cups and 15 plates which would have
been impossible left to their own
devices so let's see how they could
actually do it so we've said that
Charlie has a comparative advantage in
cups his opportunity cost of producing a
cup is lower than it is for patty it's
only 1/3 of a plate relative to three
plates so let's make him specialize in
cups so cup specialties so he's going to
specialize in cups and patty for the
same reason is going to specialize in
plates is going to specialize in plates
so him special charlie specializing in
cups means he's going to focus only on
cups so he's going to produce 30 cups
every day 30 cups every day and
specializing in plates means that she's
going to produce 30 plates every day she
let me do this in a different color she
or I'll just do the magenta she's going
to produce 30 plates every day now
imagine I'm going to make an assumption
here but imagine that they both do that
but they don't will only each only want
to have what they're producing they want
to have some combination of them so they
decide to trade and I'm going to just
fix the price here we're going to talk
more about markets in the future but I
assume that they agree to trade at one
cup one cup for one plate and this makes
sense for either of them because they're
this this trading price or you can all
say this market price is lower than
their opportunity costs so here's
Charlie he's got all of these cups there
it left to his own devices if he wanted
an extra plate he would have to spend
three cups but now in the market at this
price over here he only has to spend one
cup for an extra plate so he this makes
sense for him because the market price
is lower than his opportunity cost so he
would definitely rather get a plate in
the market than have to do it by
producing it himself it's cheaper this
way and the same thing for patty she has
all of these plates but if she wants a
cup left her by herself she would have
to spend three plates to do it she would
have to give up three plates but now in
the market she would only have to give
up one plate she would only have to give
up one plate so this is a good deal this
is lower than our opportunity cost so
she'll want to transact and so they can
do each of them so for example charlie
can keep trading cups for plates and he
could end up anywhere on this line right
over there and Patty could actually do
the same thing she could trade cups for
plates and end up someplace over there
but obviously where they end up is
dependent on how much the other one is
willing to trade but let's say they both
want to get to that 15/15 scenario so
they can both trade 15 cups to the other
person so Charlie could trade 15 cups
for 15 plates and obviously Patty would
be trading 15 plays for 15 cups and they
would both be able to get right over
there which is a situation that was
unattainable left to their own
production possibilities so hopefully
you found that interesting that you'd by
specializing they could get these gains
of trade and they specialized in the
their comparative advantage